foreign
[Applause]
think about your hometown
think about the place where important
things have happened in your life and in
the lives of those you love
now what if you woke up one day
and it was just gone
my very first film was about a town that
disappeared
I was 16 at the time and my family was
on a vacation to see the great national
parks of the West and somewhere in
Wyoming we happened upon a classic
tourist trap an old western Ghost Town
and admission was five dollars a hit and
there were six of us and my dad was
frugal so his idea was send John in
alone with the video camera and the rest
of the family will just watch the
videotape later
so I ventured in alone
and attempted to capture all of the
mystery and Mystique of this
uh Town lost to time
the old western ghost towns capture our
imagination
because they're a touchstone to
America's Pioneer history
but in time I would come to understand
that ghost towns still happen
wildfires rage earthquakes strike levees
break but more commonly it is the
Insidious slow-motion disaster
layoffs at the textile mill the closing
of a steel plant
or the suburban sprawl
that slowly sucks all life out of an old
downtown leaving it in constant decline
the covid-19 lockdown
turned every city into a temporary ghost
town and we're still not sure if some
communities can emerge from the economic
Devastation and it also taught us that
the forces that destroy cities are big
and complex and out of our control and
sometimes impossible to predict
but there is something that we can do
that we can control
that will help us navigate these
challenges we can develop Community
resilience
we can build civic pride and a strong
identity for our communities
that will give us the determination to
survive and to succeed
or to rebuild even when rebuilding from
ruins
and this is the power of the Civic story
I first learned that a story can change
the city from a barber
when I was 24 I set out to make my first
real film a feature documentary about
Route 66 once known as the mother Road
and the main street of America
and along this road is a tiny town in
northern Arizona called Seligman
and in this town is where I'm at the
barber
Angel Delgadillo
and he became one of the narrators in my
film
now hundreds of towns along Route 66
became 21st century ghost towns when
they were bypassed by the interstate
freeway system
and Angel told me about the day that
they opened Interstate 40 across Arizona
and bypassed his town of Seligman
up until that day hundreds or even
thousands of cars would pass by his
Barbershop window every day
he told me that the minute they opened
the lanes of I-40 the traffic stopped
and it was as if they had gone to the
edge of town and put up a gate and
forbidden people to come into town like
somebody had turned off a faucet
for years after this he sat in his
Barber chair and stared out at the empty
streets
and realized Seligman was dying
and he grew bitter and he grew angry
and then he realized something important
while Seligman may be off the beaten
path it wasn't obsolete
it had something special
Route 66 was an important part of
American history
and Seligman was part of that story
and he had a hunch that if the entire
Community embraced that Heritage it
would lead to a future
so they swept the sidewalks and painted
and cleaned up and petitioned the State
of Arizona to Mark The Old Road the the
route through town as a historic Highway
and it took 10 years but eventually they
did it and the State of Arizona made the
stretch from Williams through so they
went to Kingman an official historic
Route 66 Highway and in the iconic 66
Highway Shield signs returned and that's
when I met him by then his Barbershop
had morphed into a visitor center
and he was selling maps and souvenirs
and mugs and fridge magnets and
occasionally still giving a shave and a
haircut but mostly he was telling the
story of Route 66
and posing for photos and this story
their story eventually revived Seligman
and not just Seligman but dozens of
towns from Chicago to La were inspired
by Angel and Seligman
and they also embraced their Heritage
and found a way forward
on a recent trip there the Seligman
Visitor Center told me they were
averaging 160 to 200 000 visitors per
year
an angel is still posing for photos 24
hours a day is a life-size cutout in his
Barbershop
as a filmmaker focused on telling the
stories of cities and towns I've
observed something firsthand
the communities that are successful that
are managing to Stage a comeback or
Revitalize after an era of demise are
places where people of the Town seem to
know their story they know where they've
been and where they're going
no why is this why does story matter
well here's a clue it comes from a
groundbreaking psychological study done
by Emory University and the Emory center
for the study of myth and ritual in
American Life
and in the study they determined that
the single biggest predictor of a
child's emotional strength and health
and resilience was story
the more a child knew about their family
history the stronger they were
somehow the stories of their ancestors
and relatives how they overcame
obstacles and endured hardship seemed to
infuse children with confidence and
courage and Grit
was it turns out what's true for a child
is true for a community
Washington is a small town about 15
miles from my hometown of Olympia
Washington
uh it was it's about a population of
about 2 000 people it was founded as a
Sandstone City
Sandstone from the quarries in Tenino
were used to build some of the West
Coast grandest buildings churches and
libraries and railroad stations and if
you walk to 90s Main Street today you'll
see many buildings uh built from this
Sandstone as a matter of fact the city
council recently passed a law requiring
that any new building in Tenino in the
Central District must use a certain
percentage of sandstone in its
construction
and this gives the town a unique look
and a physical and visual connection to
their own story
I recently traveled to Tenino to create
a short film about this community and
their connection to their story
tenino's toughest time was the Great
Depression the only Bank in town closed
and they ran out of money there was a
run on physical currency and the city
leaders at the time decided well why
don't we just print our own
and they devised a way to print wooden
dollars and they distributed this
throughout the community to allow
Commerce to continue
fast forward
the year 2020 the coveted pandemic hits
another economic crisis well everybody
in Tenino remembered the Great
Depression and the wooden dollars and
they thought why don't we just do it
again
the 1870s era printing press that had
printed money back then was still down
at the local History Museum
so they poured the ink and fired it up
and started printing 25 covid relief
funds
and they distributed this to residents
now Walmart and Amazon do not accept
this
but that's okay in fact that's the point
Tenino businesses do and so in addition
to being a relief program it is an
economic stimulus for the local economy
encouraging people to spend their money
at local shops businesses and
restaurants the ones owned by their
family friends and Neighbors
no I noticed there was a strange Latin
phrase on this money
and I asked the mayor what it meant and
he said Loosely translated it means we
got this
and I thought there is another example
of a community that summoned confidence
in the face of a crisis empowered by
their civic story
now sometimes we get stuck in a cynical
and self-defeating narrative
welcome to Buffalo New York
in all fairness Buffalo has had a bit of
a streak of bad luck shortly after being
founded we were burned To The Ground by
the British
the Erie Canal made us one of the
richest most important cities in America
but when shipping was replaced by trains
and trucking we went from indispensable
to obsolete and in the 1950s a mass
Exodus began and we've lost roughly half
our population
the Great Blizzard of 77 made us a
constant punchline and punching bag of
national comedians
the Christmas Time closing of Bethlehem
Steel in 1983 and then four straight
Super Bowl losses in the 1990s
I won't go into the details just Google
wide right
by the time I arrived in Buffalo in 2005
you really can't blame people here for
feeling like you know we're just never
going to win
matter of fact I remember my first trip
to Kohl's a beloved neighborhood bar I
told some of the local folks that I had
just moved here from the Seattle area
and instead of saying Welcome to our
city they said what happened did you
lose a bet
this was Buffalo then a city walking
through life with a kidney sign on his
back
and since making buffalo home I have
made several short films that along with
other artists and authors and
photographers and bloggers have helped
to change the conversation in particular
the film Buffalo America's best design
City helped to reframe things
the film tells the story of why
Frederick Law almost said once called
buffalo the best planned city in America
if not the world
and then it tells how he went on to
design and build the first and best park
system in America
right here
it then honestly recounts how we
squandered that Legacy
by making a series of mistakes that did
severe damage to the city into our
neighborhoods
but in the Final Act
it tells the story of how today's
generation is rediscovering and
embracing Buffalo's Exquisite Urban
Design and the historic neighborhoods
and are committing themselves to the
long and difficult tasks of fixing and
restoring it
if the old story in Buffalo was were
unlucky
the new story is we'll make our own luck
if the old story was we're doomed the
new story is we're destined
I think one of my favorite things about
Buffalo is that it is a city with a true
narrative Arc I mean we've got highs and
lows and wins and losses and setbacks
and comebacks and I think it is this
narrative Arc and this our deep
connection to it that is our City's
secret weapon and strange appeal
I mean to be in Buffalo is to live in a
city that has embarked on the hero's
journey
what about your town
has it set foot on that Journey
I hate to say it but I think one of the
biggest threats to our cities is our own
apathy
in too many places we have given up or
given in or grown to accept things the
way they are
a well-told Civic story
can be the spark that rekindles love for
our place
it can be the spark that rekindles our
pride
the Civic story as we have learned is
not just about history
it's also about the future about what
our cities are becoming
and that's the story that we live and
participate in every day
I'm a filmmaker and I love to tell the
Civic story of a place through the
medium which I consider the modern day
campfire that flickering light in the
dark that can gather a hushed crowd to
experience something together
but there are many ways to tell the
Civic story no matter your skill set do
you like to talk to people start a
podcast series do you write or take
photos create a book or a calendar that
Chronicles The Life and Times of your
town
fight to preserve an important building
make a musical album or a mural
you could collect City memorabilia and
use it to decorate your walls and your
shelves and your bicycles and bumpers
and computers and phone cases all of
these are ways to learn and share the
Civic story
so think about your place
where are you from
does it have a past worth remembering
does it have a future worth hoping for
if so a story can change a city
thank you
[Applause]